foreign
[Music]
thank you so much for joining us today
and welcome to Bethesda game studios you
know we've been so lucky over the
decades to make the kind of games that
we love here and that's thanks to all of
you from the Elder Scrolls The Fallout
we love creating these worlds and
playing in them just as much as you do
and throughout all that time we'd often
talk about and dream up the space game
what if we could take that feeling of
being who you want to be and exploring a
new world but set it in space where you
weren't really Limited in where you
could go or what you could do and that
is Starfield obviously we've come a long
way since then with the games we've
built our technology and all of us here
in the studio we've done so much
together but well we've never tried to
make a game like this today you'll get
to hear from many on the team and see so
much of what we think makes our game
special so let's jump in and take a look
[Music]
Starfield is our first new universe in
over 25 years but it's still a Bethesda
RPG through and through where you step
into a new world and you get that
feeling of unlimited possibilities
but this time it's not just one world
it's over a thousand worlds
because the choice of where to go it's
not ours it's yours
and it wasn't until now that we had the
technology to create it
from the rocks at your feet to the
mountains in the distance
to the people and creatures that live in
these worlds
that isn't just a backdrop that moon is
actually there orbiting the planet yes
you can visit it too
quickly simulate the Galaxy around you
our next Generation lighting model uses
real-time Global illumination to light
the world based on the type of star and
the makeup of the planet's atmosphere
[Music]
we also have an all-new animation system
and of course you can play it in third
person
and you can play it in first person
we love exploration and rewarding it but
you do explore differently in this game
given its scale
that usually involves exploring an area
you've landed in
you can collect resources
do a mission and maybe even stumble upon
something unexpected
foreign
we do love stuff and all of the items
allowing you to pick everything up and
you can view all that in your data menu
this is the hub for everything you're
doing from your skills to your ship your
missions and your inventory we love to
pack a ton of detail in every object
from all of your weapons
to spacesuits
to food we just obsess over the details
and food we obsess over food
when you're done exploring you can walk
back or fast travel to your ship we have
Companions and crew you can take with
you I left Vasco here back at my ship
welcome back Captain Howard and he can
even say your name
let's head out
[Music]
our mission was to convey the Wonder and
Majesty of space exploration to evoke
the Romance of the golden age of early
space flight and we've been referring to
this approach as NASA Punk this means a
design language where the tech is
advanced yet still looks grounded and
relatable for us it's a contrast that's
where the visual interest is obviously
the NASA which is the rigid pod function
over style and then Punk which is all
about Style
you can see that visual style coming
through in your ship your ship is your
home for you and your crew and like many
of the spaces in our game it has a
slightly retro and analog touch a bit of
Lo-Fi rather than sci-fi where
everything is well used worn and lived
in alrighty what's the plan captain
this is your star map it starts with the
planet you're currently on
you can see all of its info and
resources you can choose a landing spot
or fast travel to known locations
backing out further you can view all the
planets in the system obviously the game
is big and it's here you can see planets
that have key locations missions or life
on them versus the many planets that are
Barren but resource heavy
zoom out even further to see all the
systems in this part of the Galaxy
here you can plot a course to ones that
are light years away this uses your
ship's grav drive to fold space and jump
to these systems and you will need to
upgrade your shipping skills if you want
to jump to the most distant ones but for
now we'll plot a course to the Alpha
Centauri system where we can find the
city of New Atlantis
foreign
space maintain your current course while
we scan your ship's cargo
[Music]
scan complete
are cleared for landing at new Atlantis
[Music]
as soon as you land in a city like new
Atlantis your eyes are guided upwards to
just these boundless vast buildings
it's the biggest city we've ever made
not just in size but also in the amount
of custom art
crowds and quests
so the main focus when we're designing a
city is obviously what supports the
story we try and tell as many small
stories as possible this is a colony war
memorial it's a few moments of gameplay
that make the space feel like it's full
of real characters that are going about
their day-to-day lives it's paralyzed if
you really stop and think about it buddy
it's coffee it's also where your
adventure with constellation begins
[Music]
foreign
we have a lot to talk about by the time
you meet them constellation is sort of
seen as this mythical group most people
don't even know they exist anymore
they're the last true explorers in the
galaxy and they're trying to find the
answers to some of Humanity's biggest
questions
so alien and I'm certain one of them
reached out and spoke to you
[Music]
the artifact if you could place it on
the table here
oh my God look at how it's coming
together that means set built by an
intelligence outside the settled systems
it's definitely an Eclectic cast of
characters you've got Sarah Morgan the
ex-soldier in Adventurer now
constellations leader Mateo the
Theologian who believes that there's
definitely something else out there Noel
the gifted scientist and Sarah Morgan's
Protege and Walter a very successful
businessman in the settled systems and
constellations financier anything goes
as long as you have the money there's
also Vlad the ex-pirate Sam Coe the
former Space Cowboy and baron you know
what I hate about these Pirates
completely resistant to my otherwise
irresistible charm
the journey you take with constellation
is just the first that many you'll
embark on the settled systems is home to
all kinds of different stories people
and Adventures for you to uncover
[Music]
the United Colonies is where you'll find
new Atlantis the first major human
settlement in space
people who live here value law
discipline and the legacy of humanity
they consider themselves the true
children of Earth you ever think of
joining up with a Vanguard of the United
Colonies even get your UC citizenship
new Atlantis isn't the only city within
the United Colonies
the city of Sedonia on Mars to this day
serves as the largest Mining facility
for the United Colonies
beyond the United Colonies reach you
might find yourself in a much more wild
and independent Coalition of star
systems
[Music]
this is Freestar Collective space
capital of the Freestar Collective is
Aquila City
Stone route inn is an Aquila City
fixture
Ranger relies on judgment and intuition
to do to do best for the people
neon started out as a fishing platform
but is now known throughout the cell
systems as a pleasure City where almost
anything goes if you've got morality
issues this definitely isn't the job for
you
[Music]
ryugen is hiring the best and brightest
of today for our future tomorrow
everyone has been chewed up and ground
up by Neon try not to get yourself
killed alright
outside the bounds of civilized space
there are still plenty of unclaimed
systems to explore but these areas are
also home to the most hostile factions
in the galaxy
the Great Serpent hungers all heathens
shall be made Dust In Time
a new face this is the face of a brave
Runner here to challenge the Red Mile
they think the Galaxy is theirs they are
wrong it belongs to the Crimson Fleet it
always has
in Starfield we're pushing our cities
and settlements further than we ever
have before it's all there waiting for
you a slice of Humanity's future
so ready to get out there
[Music]
throughout the Galaxy there are so many
things to see and stories to experience
but the most important story is the one
that you tell
I'm the type of person who spends hours
in character creation and I think people
are going to be really excited when they
see all of the improvements we've made
one of the biggest overhauls was done
through our character generation system
we scanned a wide range of faces from
different age groups and ethnicities and
by mixing and matching out that data we
were able to create a highly detailed
and diverse characters we use that exact
system to create all the characters and
NPCs you're going to see in the game so
any character you see almost always is a
character you could make yourself
foreign
[Music]
hey come on come on okay take it easy
you were out cold uh no physical damage
mentally the jury's still out
you know who you are new recruit for
Argos extractors ring any bells
any of this look familiar
[Music]
you start your character creation
Journey as though you're cycling through
employee records you'll pick from a
lineup of 40 presets and that'll be your
starting point
your journey from there can be as
detailed or as quick as you want it to
be this new system has more to offer
than ever before
it's also the simplest character
generation system we've ever had we let
the player get as close as possible to
make whatever they want with the various
facial morphs you can blend together the
thermostatic and makeup blemishes scars
piercings teeth settings it's a lot but
I think it's the most fun to use
character creation is more than just how
you look this is also where you start to
decide who you want to be that's where
backgrounds come in
backgrounds give you a bit of backstory
and starts you out with three basic
skills from Chef to Dusty you know the
crew still has a bedding pool about
which restaurant critic you must have
crossed to wind up here what's great
about backgrounds is you never know when
yours is going to come in handy you
could be in the middle of a fancy
restaurant talking to some guy and
suddenly you learn he needs a beast
hunter to help track down a monster fine
I probably should stick to professionals
anyway given what happened the last time
we're also giving you the option to
customize your build even further by
letting you pick up the three traits
traits are completely optional and they
come with their own advantages and
disadvantages you could choose to meet
your biggest fan
he'll join your crew and he'll give you
gifts if you're willing to put up with
this constant commentary I can't believe
I get to stand near you breathing the
same air I've got to have every molecule
my favorite trait is kid stuff you have
to pay some credits to support your
parents but they're very sweet and it's
really fun to go visit them honey we got
ourselves a visitor oh my God I came
across some hostile zealots in space but
because I had chosen a treat that made
me the same religion as them I was able
to get by without any issues
there's another great one that gives you
a damage Buff when your health is low
but mercenaries will randomly show up
and try to kill you
no matter what you choose there will be
plenty of ways for you to tell your
story and if you want to remove a trait
there are ways to do that too what a
view It's A Feast for the eyes off we go
another
we'll let you discover that on your own
[Music]
please
once you've built the perfect character
that's when your journey can really
begin
we took what we loved about skills and
perks from our previous games and put
them together to create an all new skill
system
each time you level up you get a skill
point which can be used to unlock or
rank up skills
ranks are unlocked by completing
challenges associated with that skill
[Music]
become increasingly difficult as you
work your way to higher ranks
foreign with our five different skill
trees and four ranks per skill there's a
lot to choose from
[Music]
sociology is skill because it lets you
mind control aliens
[Music]
boost pack out of the gate I'm boost
packing everywhere
xing out my physical tree so I can get
neuro strikes and just punch my way
through combat
that one's a lot of fun
invest in the skills that suit your play
style
I'm very much a stealth player so I'm
out there Pig pocketing everyone
my favorite part about being stealthy
slowly creeping through vents like
you're in a movie
and then jumping out and springing on
people
[Music]
whenever possible I like to talk my way
through situations is there is off
limits
fine I'll issue you an access card I'm
more of a run and Gun player
I like doing the death from above thing
where I boost pack over guys and I throw
land mines at them
oh mama
you're gonna pay for that
I like blowing stuff up
[Music]
exploration is a key aspect of all our
games
in Starfield there are four star
assistants with new life resources and
Adventures
[Music]
our team worked hard to strike a balance
between fun and realism we study data
from NASA and a multitude of other
sources to help us make the world feel
believable
from the way we approached planetary
atmospheres to the way we place biomes
based on the planet's distance from the
Sun
once we had created a grounded world we
could start looking at all the things
that make that world fun
when you leave a planet and head into
space
you'll be navigating asteroid Fields
having chance meetings with interesting
strangers dog fighting in space and
exploring derelict ships
[Music]
it's all out there
ultimately it's about rewarding your
curiosity because whether it's on the
surface of a planet the alleys of a city
or the vastness of space
you never know what you'll find
[Music]
space exploration is possible thanks to
your ship your ship is almost like
having another character or home you can
make all your own I think you'll be
blown away by the amount of stuff you
can do
you can buy a ship I'm sure you can find
something you like customize and upgrade
that ship
and hire a crew to keep it up and
running
[Music]
it all starts in spaceports
every Spaceport has a ship technician
where you can purchase sell and modify
ships anything I can help you with
maybe you start off with a speedy
fighter that's perfect for bounty
hunting
then you might round out your ship
roster with a hulking space freighter to
run cargo missions or even do a little
smuggling
for now though we're going to take our
starting ship the frontier
and make some changes
you can customize and upgrade everything
you see here
and you have two ways to do that
you can quickly upgrade individual
systems like your weapons or Shields
or you can deep dive and enter the
shipbuilder mode here you can change
anything from the systems to the look
and layout
adding a new habitat module can give you
more room for crew
adding cowling can change your ship's
overall silhouette
an improved grav Drive allows for longer
distance space jumps
you can even fully customize your paint
job to get the exact look you want
the parts you choose to build with don't
just affect your ship's stats
they'll also affect what you can do
inside your ship
you can have modules for crafting
or for storing and displaying your
weapons
starfield's in-game ship manufacturers
bring their own look and feel to every
piece of your ship
from living quarters to cargo holds mess
halls and control rooms
thank you
our modified Frontier is a practical
ship but with a little creativity your
ship can look like almost anything you
want
but one of my favorite ways of
customizing
she's um
platypus as I called it
where I had like a giant tail to it
[Music]
and we've done spiders we've done mix
so it's really whatever your imagination
is
and while you can build your home Among
the Stars the way you want to you're
probably not the only person who will
call your ship home
[Applause]
[Music]
ready to lift off when you are captain
engines ready
Frontier is fueled and ready captain
some of the members of constellation can
join you on your journey these
companions can serve on your crew and
they'll always be there when you travel
we'll be traveling together until we
either find an artifact or this lead
Runs Dry
each companion comes with their own
valuable skills for your ships and
outposts
as well as unique quest lines eventually
some friendships might blossom into
romance I don't know that I've ever
really loved anyone except you and if
you're looking for a little extra help
on your ship you can always hire
additional crew at spaceports got any
room on your
menu like me
you'll also meet potential crew members
out in the world still think there might
be a spot for me on your ship I gotta
get off this rock
assigned crew to your ship or outposts
and their unique skills will affect how
they run
and just like companions most crew
members can lend a hand in the field
take Bosco for instance
these designed around the core basics of
a NASA machine please avoid getting shot
you might die I still want to give it
almost a humanoid personality so I
elongated the limbs this tends to make
him feel more human-like and give him a
little personality it is a shame
exploration requires so much bloodshed
using the ship building tools and crew
selection features in Starfield you'll
be able to build and Captain the ship of
your dreams
[Music]
let's take to the sky
we're putting you in the cockpit of your
very own spaceship and telling you that
you can do pretty much anything and that
is really cool for us as Developers
this flight should be exciting and
dangerous and you should feel like
you're in complete control every step of
the way
we've extended that sense of control to
ship combat it's not about just hitting
your triggers to fire your weapons
complex dance between your piloting
skills and our power allocation system
boosting power to your engines will make
your ship faster
powering up the ground dries will
shorten the amount of time it takes
before you can make a jump
and moving your power to your weapons
and shields means you're ready for a
fight
you should always be on your toes
because you're not alone out there
[Music]
unlocking the targeting control system
skill will allow you to zero in on
specific subsystems of the ship you
target
after destroying an enemy ship you can
loot The Remains from your cockpit
you can always turn any ship that
engages you into scrap
but you could also take a more personal
approach by docking with the Enemy
vessel and boarding their ship
once you've taken control of an enemy
ship it's yours
at your Fleet and retrieve it at any
Spaceport
but space is way more than fighting for
your life
just like when you're PlanetSide there
are plenty of sights to see and stops to
make on the way to your next adventure
like these massive star yards
[Music]
Walk The Halls talk to the crew maybe
get talked into buying a whole new ship
a civilian in moist let's see about
getting you a proper ship one worthy of
you maybe you'll dock with a gigantic
Battleship like the UC vigilance
foreign
elbows with the Galaxy's wealthy Elite
on a cruise ship fit for the Stars
there are plenty of personal encounters
to be had as well you can hail any ship
you come across to trade swap info or
maybe even commit an act of piracy let's
do this when I'm playing I generally go
crazy
um I definitely go like the more piracy
routes I want to take over ships I'm
going to board ships I'm like this is
now mine I steal all these sandwiches
and put them you know in my cargo hold
that I have specifically for sandwiches
I don't want to play the hero but I want
to go out and just start taking things
from people as quickly as possible
some strangers might be looking for a
little human Connection in the darkness
of space
hello stranger I just finished cooking
up some food if you want to come on over
just pop on by
some of the best moments are the ones
you discover on your own
the thing I love most about Starfield is
that it is a Bethesda game through and
through it's really about going to
strange new places meeting interesting
people and getting sidetracked on zany
Adventures then realizing two hours
later that you're involved in a
completely new story you'll
we thought we were the only ones to
leave Earth that DNA is so present here
it's in our Random Encounters it's in
our handcrafted quests
and it feels so cool to play it and just
make your own path in this universe
there are over a thousand planets out
there just waiting for you to visit
floors
breaking ground on new planets exploring
every inch of a mostly untouched Galaxy
we want you to feel hope
awe and wonder
fear
we're giving you a massive playground
and a ton of toys and just setting you
free
[Music]
hey everybody we've shown you so much
stuff but we thought we'd just take a
little break and show you something a
little bit different you know we put so
much detail into our game worlds and we
love the opportunity to bring that into
the real world with our Collector's
Editions and for this game uh we've done
a watch it is the constellation
explorers watch this is the watch that
you actually get in the game that acts
as part of your HUD where it's the
compass and then environmental
information it connects to your phone to
give you notifications and other
information and we've also designed this
really cool case that it comes with
eastvon yeah we really took as much care
and designed as cases we did to watch
our attention to detail and to gain
totally translates to this inspired by
the cases that the astronauts used
during the Apollo era to bring back
samples from the moon it's got an
intricate locking mechanism authentic
heavy comes with a constellation patch
native strap and the overall
functionality and believability of this
as something that would exist in the
world in the Starfield Universe oh and
hey take this you'll find it very useful
out there and it even tells the time
we actually have something else now that
we're part of Xbox we get to work with
the amazing people on the Xbox Hardware
team and together we have created this
custom limited edition Starfield
controller it's awesome it is now you
know our favorite controller we love
this because it's inspired by the actual
controls of your spaceship
and not only that
we've created the first ever custom
headset with Xbox and this is a perfect
pairing with that controller
Frontier
on your signal
ready
for departure
[Music]
in every one of our games we always put
so much care into all those little
details that breathe life into our
worlds
but Starfield isn't just a Bethesda game
studios world it's a Bethesda game
studios Galaxy
so why go this big with Starfield
because we want to give you freedom on a
galactic level
the freedom to experience both the
exciting planets
and The Quiet Ones
scanning a planet before you land is a
great way to get a sneak peek at the
available resources you can use for
crafting building and customizing I
think what's cool about this whole
system that we we generate the planet
itself as a procedural content but the
handcrafted content itself comes as the
player Explorer
our system builds a planet as the player
approaches it and we stitch together the
luck of terrain after that we have the
system that adds interested locations
for the player to explore creatures to
encounter
or and plans to pick up
thank you
it allows us to add that touch of
environmental storytelling that Bethesda
is known for
teachers have been disrupting our
experiments their habitat isn't far from
here if you could take care of them for
us we would be in your debt so even if
your friends were to visit the same
planet that you had you would have a
different story to tell
[Music]
thank you
it's completely up to you how you want
to interact with each planet whether you
want to explore and see what you can
find
Harvest resources and be on your way
simply taking the views
with the help of your scanner you'll
chart the Uncharted and discover exotic
wildlife
if you have the skills you can even
figure out that certain creatures and
plants you can build an outpost and
produce resources from those plants and
animals you can get experience and
rewards for fully surveying planets and
fully serving a whole system
[Music]
concepting these creatures we really
wanted to think of them as natural to
the environment we didn't want alien
monsters we wanted native wildlife
something you've never seen before
when it comes to our exteriors when the
sun moves all that light is calculated
in real time through the atmosphere our
biggest goal for lighting with Starfield
was to make the game feel more filmic to
use lighting and color to really make it
feel more cinematic
oh
[Music]
foreign
after some exploring you can find a spot
to set up a base camp
outposts can be built almost anywhere on
any planet
and the habitat modules come in all
shapes and sizes filling all different
purposes you can even live in them
assign crew and companions to work at
your outposts for added bonuses and set
up extractors to harvest resources while
you're away something cool we have this
time is we have a new flycam where you
can toggle between on foot building or
you can now use a top-down isometric
camera which helps plan out larger parts
of the Outpost and placing those larger
halves so that way you can really plan
your structures and what the overall
feel of your Outpost is and then when
you're on your feet you can really
decorate and fine-tune things much
easier
foreign
[Music]
and research stations in your Outpost to
utilize any resources you find or
already have
mod your weapons to adapt them to your
playstyle different weapon sights and
Scopes larger magazines a selection of
grips and barrels different ammunition
like Explosive Rounds
all you stealth players out there will
surely need a suppressor
you can also choose to go Hands-On with
melee weapons
always a delicate balance between like
what's realistic what's Sim and what's
Hollywood and I think we sort of err on
the side of like what's fun for the
player
with Starfield we've completely
overhauled our combat
it's more Dynamic the animations are
more fluid
it just feels great
we probably have more mods and more
weapons in this game than I want to say
any other game we've done before
there's a lot of variety
upgraded gear is just one of the many
factors to pay attention to when
engaging in combat you may need to
switch things up based on your
environment
gravity is different for each planet and
boost packs are excellent for getting
around
and for giving you an edge in combat
[Music]
sometimes you'll even feel like you're
flying
[Music]
zero gravity environments pose a
different challenge firing a ballistic
weapon in zero g will actually push you
backwards
energy weapons on the other hand offer a
more stable shooting experience
we also have mag weapons
these are high powered electromagnetic
induction ballistic arrays each Barrel
has its own targeting laser and can dish
out some serious damage
amazing
whether you want to get up close and
personal with your own two Fists
or you like more compact weapons like
pistols and submachine guns
or maybe you prefer something bigger
starfield's got you covered
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thanks again for being with us today we
are just so grateful that you've taken
the time and spent it here I know there
was probably a lot to take in there's a
lot to the game even more than we could
show here you know as we play it we're
always sharing these unique and special
moments that only a game like this can
bring
when I think about what makes it special
it really is the people here
this game is a reflection of the
incredible and passionate team that made
it all of them putting something special
of themselves into it so let's hear some
of their favorite moments
I love the way that our final
combination of all the new tech has come
together to create some of the most
beautiful sunsets and sunrises we've
ever had in any of our games
word that comes to mind is vast
I like to use our photo mode to take
Rockstar photos
I just love that constant feel of
Discovery and wow I can't believe that
there's more here I'm most excited about
our Outpost Building Systems
my favorite part is every time you step
out on a planet it's a unique experience
I spent all this time building your ship
and you see it on the landing pad these
things are gigantic it's the kind of
thing that you just can't get anywhere
else
there's something about seeing a tower
over in the distance and going I know
the gravity is low here I think I can
make that jump
my favorite part is biomes spaceships
audio design planets the day night cycle
those details matter to me diplomacy
exploration Freedom the ending basket
obviously I love the robot so much the
incredible amount of Worlds we created
sniper rifles come on lever action
rocket launcher brain sprout
I love but some people might find creepy
I don't know and that's right bam
the thing that I enjoy most about the
game is the freedom to be who you want
to be do what you want to do
it's what you've come to expect from a
Bethesda title but on a much bigger
scale
[Music]
on behalf of all of us we can't wait for
you to play Starfield and make your own
special moments
[Music]
all right
play it day one with Game Pass